[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is the
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our terrific guest today is an
organizational psychologist and an
author
dr carlin borisenko welcome to
trigonometry thank you so much
for having me excited to be here oh it's
great to have you listen before we get
in
to the conversation for anyone who
doesn't know who you are just tell
everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been your journey to the
problematic seat in which you find
yourself now
yeah so i'm an organizational
psychologist and i that what this
essentially that means is i work with
businesses all over the world to help
create better working environments
things like that and
that was a space i had been playing in
since about 2012
until i had the well some would say
fortune some would say misfortune
of going to a trump rally as a democrat
of 20 years and
i had no idea really what i was going to
find but i live in i live in new
hampshire in the states and so i had
seen all the
democratic candidates for president at
some point or another in person because
we're very spoiled and
donald trump came to town and i decided
to go to a trump rally and write about
my experiences
and the article kind of went viral on
the internet which is how i got thrust
into
the problematic space rather quickly and
unexpectedly well we'll get on to that
we'll get on to the political stuff but
actually francis and i wanted to chat to
you about the
the workspace stuff for a bit which is
you know an area of expertise that we
don't often cover so go ahead francis
no absolutely so what we're seeing at
the moment because of covid and the
covid and corona and all the rest of it
is the way we work
fundamentally change almost overnight
so could you explain a little bit to us
about how the ways we've worked have
changed and what are the implications do
you think
about these changes and these rapid
changes we're experiencing
yeah so i mean a lot to unpack there but
i think the the first thing
was just the absolute shock of how
quickly work had to change
and when you think about the the
elements that people
need psychologically to be set up for
success at work
it starts at a very basic level of
things that people don't even think
about like
do i have a desk that's not broken to
sit
at do i have a lamp in my office that is
not going to give me a headache do i
have a chair
that's not going to give me back
problems do i have a printer do i have a
fax machine do i have all these office
supplies
these when you're in the workplace seem
like a no-brainer we don't even consider
them but
when all of a sudden you have to take
your workforce and move
everyone home and no one has an office
set up and no one knows what that means
and
half the office knows how to use things
like zoom and half the office has
no idea what's going on it creates
instantly a lot of problems and
consternation and anxiety that's
frankly even worse than when people are
afraid of losing their jobs
which was the second element that was
added on top of it because not only
are all of a sudden everyone uh leaving
and going home
but there's also fear of who's going to
lose their job next with these mass
layoffs these furloughs no one really
knows
how a lot of businesses are going to
fare and so that's the next level of
psychological
psychological safety that was inhibited
when everything first started now
as things kind of calm down and people
started to
settle into what this was going to be it
actually gets
worse in a little bit of a nefarious way
because
now people are spending all day on zoom
or all day on webex or teams or whatever
tool they happen to be using
and at least with the clients that i've
worked with
the last couple months have been
incredibly painful
for them in terms of using technology to
communicate
to the point because they just get sick
of it they get tired of being on their
computer all day
um and and so what happens is at that
point team communication
starts to break down simply because no
one wants to do it
and when we're looking at what is what
are the core attributes of highly
functioning highly resilient teams
the number one thing that says highly
resilient teams apart from every other
type
is psychological safety they trust each
other they have each other's backs
they're communicating openly they're
able to have productive conflict
every single one of these attributes is
inhibited when we're going to a
full-time
work-at-home scenario and so that's what
a lot of teams are managing through
right now people are just sick of it
they want to go back to the off well
some want to go back to the office and
then some are scared of going back to
the office because i'm going to go i'm
going to catch the virus and die
if i go back to the office and so it is
a very tough place for organizations to
be in
and and um you know i actually have not
seen many that are that are handling it
very
well because we're talking about up and
down the leadership chain
we're having all these problems um that
are coming up with communication and
trust and
just being worn out being burnt out and
colin
a lot of people are saying that what
we're seeing now is the death of the
office
in real time this idea that we commute
40 minutes to an hour to an hour and a
half to go somewhere to go and then sit
at a desk for eight hours and then
commute an hour and a half back
that is an obsolete idea do you agree
with that or do you think the answer is
slightly more nuanced
i think it's much more nuanced than that
i think the reality is that we're
talking
about um phasing out the office
environment it is
a lot easier to do that at tech
companies like
twitter or facebook than it is at places
like you know
an insurance company or um uh
you know i i have this one client that
they make socks and so i mean they there
have to be people there i have
clients that are credit unions well
there have to be people
in the banks we have to be able to go to
the bank and so it does become a much
more nuanced discussion and
frankly it's not beneficial to phase out
the office
we need to have these face-to-face human
interactions
otherwise we literally forget that our
co-workers are human
right and then you have all these
interpersonal problems popping up so
not only do i think this is not the
death of the traditional office i think
that's a little premature
i think it's not even ideal for the
traditional office to die off
it's really interesting that you make
that point because francis and i were
talking just before we started this
conversation
which we're already really enjoying and
look forward to continuing but i was
saying to him like
we need to get back into the studio you
know we're having these brilliant guests
you scott adams brett weinstein ben you
know
so many people that we love talking to
but i just watched one of our interviews
done in studio
and i just feel like it's a whole
different thing you know
and it's a whole different thing to
watch it's a whole different thing to be
part of it's a whole different thing to
be interviewed in that way
like i i'm not sure that this excitement
about uh you know moving back
uh moving moving into this kind of
online space entirely is going to work
and i suspect the point you make about
forgetting that
other people are human will tie into the
political stuff we talk about later but
i imagine
uh that some of the divisiveness we've
seen politically and
psychologically recently is a big
product of that wouldn't you say
i i absolutely agree and then you add on
to it hang on i'll even i'll even do
this then you add on to it this
we're literally covering our faces we're
covering the thing that we use to
express
our emotions i mean this is like this is
a perfect
storm which is going to create a really
difficult scenarios for teams to
function in the workplace but
also i mean just looking out more
broadly if if we look at all the karen's
attacking people in the stores for not
wearing a mask i mean
we have started to dehumanize each other
and it's very concerning to me it's very
concerning
not only in the workplace and i believe
that work is important because
it gives people a purpose it gives
people a place to focus their energy
fundamentally there are really two types
of people in the world they're creators
and there are destroyers
and if you're not creating something and
focusing your energy in a positive
direction well
then you're going to end up like the
sjws out pulling down statues in the
street because they don't have anything
else that's more productive to do
and so that's what work it gives people
and when workplaces
are you know becoming all about how much
time i'm spending on my computer that
becomes a problem
another factor is that working from home
is a
different type of environment than going
into the office and it's one
that it is very very easy to lose
work-life balance because what happens
people kind of roll out of bed they
don't even get dressed or
shower and they just roll right into the
office and oftentimes you'll find that
people don't eat
throughout the day they forget to take
breaks they forget to take
walks maybe during lunch they work way
later they stop going to the gym
entirely and so work life balance also
gets
really out of whack and people just
become generally a lot more unhealthy
which
makes them a lot more consternated when
they're in the work environment which
again
only adds to those interpersonal issues
and
there's been a lot of people who are
saying that actually what we're going to
start to see
is our cities becoming more and more
obsolete
when people realize that they can work
from home that they don't actually have
to be
amongst the hustle and the bustle when
they're gonna be
on zoom four days a week what do you
reckon about that
i i mean i think i i don't know that
cities are going to become
obsolete i think that there is certainly
something to it and i think we're seeing
this in the states where people
stop living in the cities but certainly
there are always ways to commute in
um i think that you know my biggest
concern with this entire fair affair is
just the dehumanization that's going on
all around we've got to stop being
afraid to be around each other and
whether that's from
the virus or it's just we've gotten used
to this new
normal of working in our houses and
never seeing each other
the more that the the longer that this
continues without some sort of
corrective action to try to
steer us back to where we were before
all this started um
i'm i'm becoming increasingly concerned
that this really is
our normal now i mean people keep
calling it the new normal this is our
normal we've been at this now what since
march so
that's several months that's more than
enough time to develop a habit
and so all the work that we took to get
into this scenario we're now going to
have to do the same work to get
back out and reclaim a normal where
it is common to be around each other and
have conversations in person and do work
in person
and that's going to be a whole process
to get us back there but colin you've
you've just said that you know this is
the new normal and you know where we
we've become not comfortable but
accustomed to being isolated
what effect does that have on the human
being and the human mind
being isolated not being used to
interacting with people
not used to socializing well i think
it makes it it makes it incredibly
uncomfortable when you
are in social situations i mean it's
kind of roughly akin to
you know i guess so i suppose being an
introvert going to
a networking event now it's not as
though you can't engage in those social
situations if you've gotten used to
being alone
but it's going to take a lot more energy
to do it so
you know we'll think back in olden times
when we used to have networking events
that
we were going to you know for an
introvert like me it took a lot to get
me out to a networking event i didn't
want to go i didn't want to be around
people i didn't know and be
uncomfortable and all this good stuff
and have to make chit chat
um but i did it because you have to do
it and when you do it you just get
really tired from it right it just takes
extra energy
and so what people need to realize is
that we can
still have these human interactions we
can still
meet up in person we can still do these
things
but because we have gotten used to the
isolation it's simply going to take more
energy it's going to take more
determination to actually see it through
maybe it's it's useful to liken it to
you know going back to the gym when you
haven't been there for
three months as i recently had to do
when my gym reopened again
and you know it's going to be painful
and you don't want to go
and you are not looking forward to it
but you know it's good for you and so
you do it anyway
and it isn't a little bit painful at
first yes it absolutely is painful but
once you get over that hump
i mean maybe it would be helpful for
people to visualize like wouldn't it be
nice to be
sitting at a restaurant and have people
around me again or having a conversation
in person if we can think about
how it felt to do those things when we
really enjoyed them
that'll make it easier for us to get
back there
yeah it's it's an interesting point and
when you talk about creators and
destroyers that that's
that's something that reminded me it's
actually true of animals as well like if
you keep a dog at home and you don't
give it
enough exercise and etc it starts
you know chewing stuff and tearing stuff
apart and
i mean obviously the other thing that's
affecting workplaces now in a very big
way
is the whole conversation about race um
people are being required to read
certain books and being
uh forced to accept certain ideologies
as being the
the truth sent down from from above
uh what do you think will be the impact
of some of those things on the way that
we're having these conversations and the
way people relate to each other in the
workplace and outside of it
yeah i'm actually terrified of what i'm
seeing in the workplace in response to
george floyd's death with um you know
certain books the books that will not be
named
being mandated um that being mandated
out to the workforce they're actually
buying copies of the book in bulk giving
it out to everyone
forming book clubs around these
anti-racist ideas
bringing in high dollar value
anti-racist trainers and
by the way there is absolutely zero
evidence
that anti-racist training works and has
any positive effect
on the organization there's zero
evidence in the literature of that but
organizations are spending tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands we know
that the
united states government spent 5 million
dollars
on this training to indoctrinate
government employees into anti-racist
ideals and
this is actually the most terrifying
thing to me
because fundamentally what this
literature says is
you as a person do not matter the only
thing that matters is your skin color
and i have to treat you
according to your skin color and talk to
you according to your skin color and
and that means that and that's an
incredibly disempowering
position to be in because not only does
it not really give me the ability to
communicate with you just as an
average person to get what i need um it
also is
incredibly disempowering to people who
to to
people of color to be honest it doesn't
give them a whole lot of leeway as well
it actually takes their empowerment away
and says
you are at the whim of what the group
says or why because i mean those aren't
really the people that feel it the most
when they speak up it's not white people
like me
it's people of color who speak up and
said i don't want to be infantilized in
this way in the workplace
they're the ones that get it the worst
and so i am deeply concerned about the
impact of
anti-racist training on things like team
camaraderie collaboration
connection being able to engage in
productive conflict because every
time you engage in conflict it becomes
what has become
a microaggression every time and so it's
it's going to start tearing teams apart
and really is going to inhibit
um resiliency and and productivity in
the work environment
i mean one of the things we should
probably say at this point just for the
low iq people
is that we're all against racism i think
this is like a disclaimer you're nodding
that people won't be able to see let me
okay let me make sure that everyone can
see this three of us we're all nodding
we're against racism right uh but but
the point is
what you're talking about is it's very
specific i did look like brainwashing
mate i'm gonna be honest with you that's
what we do here trigonometry
we convince people not to be racist
francis remember that's that's the goal
of the show
but that's not what people say on
twitter but anyway
they're very true uh but but the point
my point is colin
when most people because you're an
expert in this and the two of us aren't
experts but we've been paying attention
let's say and because of what we do
most people when they hear anti-racism
training like that's a good thing right
i mean we want to train people not to be
racist right if you can help it
that'd be fantastic so when you talk
about
anti-racism training the indoctrination
you're talking about and that it doesn't
work
just explain to someone who may be less
you know
aware of everything that's happening
what it is that you're talking about
what are people being taught
what are they being told what are they
being told they have to do
now etc well i mean it is brilliant
branding isn't it for anti-racist
training it's very orwellian
it's very orwellian branding because
what they're essentially saying
is um you you you as an individual
do not matter you are not an individual
and you've been telling francis this for
years
you know his russian background and well
and in fact
being being pursued being an individual
in terms of an anti-racist framework is
actually part of a white supremacist
culture in organizations you know what
and other components that they're going
to teach you as part of the white
supremacy are things like
meetings or writing things down
or having goals or being on time these
are all part of
white supremacist culture in
organizations
that need to be dismantled in
anti-racist training now
are you exaggerating here you this is
what they're actually saying meetings
are racist i am 100 not exaggerating in
fact there is a
six-page document that i have that the
city of seattle
was using in their anti-racism training
about what is that white supremacy
culture is that
enumerates every single one of these
things even
expecting a high quality work product
white supremacist
and so and and the problem with this is
these trainings come in and they teach
you all the ways in which you are a
white supremacist at work
but they don't offer alternatives they
don't say here's what we should do
instead they come
and they say white supremacy bad and
they very
literally make you confess your sins if
you're a white person because they're
also
by the way to call it i mean this is why
i say anti-racist training is orwellian
the city of seattle when they did their
mandated
city anti-racist training segregated it
by the races
there was a separate training for white
employees of the city of seattle than
there were black employees
of the city of have separate drinking
fountains as well just to spice things
up
well they probably did and i'll give you
even one better the white employees were
asked to come in on a vacation day that
they had already planned
to participate in the anti-racist
training voluntarily of course
wow so they were segregating people
because of their race you received
different
training and uh i i think the question
is like haven't we made this mistake
before
i mean it's separate but equal if there
ever was a case of it isn't there
yeah right no but and but they never
offer an alternative they all they
basically do when they come in and
do this training is they say all of
these things that white people
have brought onto the organization these
are all bad and so we have to dismantle
them
now an extra thing i'm going to throw in
here is i've actually analyzed that
six page document that they say is all
white supremacy in organizations
and i'll tell you this absolutely none
of those things in organizations have to
do with skin color
a lot of the grievances they have
actually have to do with the work styles
that people bring with them to work so
your work style is things like
how you communicate how you collaborate
do you like to work at a fast pace do
you like to wake at a slow pace are you
open and friendly are you more
questioning and skeptical all of these
things
make up an individual's work style and
all of the conflicts
that we see coming up that are that are
grieved in this white supremacist
document
are all work style conflicts i can
explain every single one of them by
saying
this work style does this this work
style does not and so
they're trying to frame it as though
this is an issue of race all white
people do this
all people of color do not and it's just
not true
and there is no evidence to back it up
and calling
you we keep using this term white
supremacy and white supremacists
now when i think of a white supremacist
maybe because i'm a bit backward and a
bit ignorant
i imagine a ku klux klan member in a
little pointy hat saying
awful racial epithets etc etc etc
is that what we mean now by a white
supremacist it is not what we mean by a
white supremacist what we mean by a
white supremacist is someone who
is white
oh well i'm not i'm nothing more to add
like honestly he's talking about you
mate
you are the face of white supremacy
as that is for white supremacists if
that's the case
well i don't know about that the white
supremacy movement is therefore [ __ ]
if i'm the leader of it
okay i mean you put it in a very blunt
way but
i i have to say based on what i am
hearing
as the conversation about white
supremacy it's starting to feel a little
bit like that is what they mean
it's exactly what they mean in fact it's
actually laid out
in the books i can i can point the
passages in
the cursed book that shall not be named
in which they actually say
that white people do not exist in a
culture outside of white supremacy
okay so so all white people are white
supremacists well
yeah i i have i have a feeling that
might not be a healthy way of looking at
things
um you know if i may say so without
being cancelled
um so you talk about this being
implemented in the workplace
i i can't imagine this would have
anything other than a horrific
impact on relationships between people
in the in those
workplaces but i imagine in terms of
broader society
the impact of that of re-racializing
everything
is going to be detrimental as well isn't
it well yeah and what i'm about to say
it can apply to workplaces it can also
apply to broader society so one of the
components of
the anti-racist training is that white
people
are responsible for calling out other
white people on
their racist actions it's part of your
responsibility of being an anti-racist
and that's what they mean
when they say it's not enough not to be
racist to be an
active anti-racist so you have to call
people out when they're doing anything
that they perceive as as white
supremacists and and
you get points of course for calling
people out on their racist actions so it
almost becomes like a game like
who can score the most supremacy points
and all this stuff
and so when you're when you it's
essentially you've got a bunch of spies
around you now
looking for reasons to call you out
because if they call you out that means
that they
are more anti-racist than you and so
instead of incentivizing
team camaraderie and collaboration and
interpersonal relationships and
giving people the benefit of the doubt
actually you know what's funny
is um there was recently an infographic
on a website for one of the smithsonian
museums in the states
in which they said that having positive
intent
assuming positive intent of people is a
white supremacist attribute so
we can't we can't be giving people the
benefit of the doubt any longer either
so when you take
these attributes and you apply them to
teamwork in organizations
it is going to go completely off the
rails and one of the things that is so
insidious about this training and i
frankly don't really understand it
is it seems to suck people right into it
and it's almost like once this training
happens once these ideas take root
it is incredibly hard to to facilitate
teamwork to facilitate collaboration
to facilitate even normal conversations
so in the work environment it's going to
be incredibly detrimental but
also in society where we have so many
divisions right now
it makes it near impossible for people
who even have the most
minor disagreements to have productive
conversations
francis before you take cover let me
just just say this one thing so colin
you're saying
meetings are white supremacists being
organized as white supremacy
having positive intent and assuming
positive intent on behalf of other
people
that's white supremacy working hard
creating good product these are all
are they trying to make white supremacy
really attractive is that what this is
all about
i have no i mean it seems like it
doesn't it but no
i mean i have no idea and then part of
the problem again is that they haven't
presented an alternative
well if this is white supremacy what
what what do you want
what if you want to dismantle the system
of white supremacy what are you trying
to replace it with
there's no alternative that's been
presented and
colin so we're saying all these things
you know white supremacy and all the
rest of it but
there's a cynical part of me that goes
hang on
when this affects the bottom dollar when
this affects
profits they're isn't it on the
shareholders going to be
up and up in arms and going look i don't
care about any of this
profit sit down we're going to cut this
nonsense out
well i mean you you say that and i tend
to agree with it but here's the thing
when i talk to ceos of organizations
that are
issuing their black lives matter
statements and
making bold declarations of all the
training they're going to do with their
people
they don't care about any of this stuff
they don't they don't care at all but
they're they're doing it because they
don't want the mob
to come after them that is the only
reason that they're doing it and so
ceos are actually between a rock and a
hard place right now because
if they don't issue the statement
they're going to have people saying well
why don't you issue this thing that what
are we doing what are we doing to
dismantle white supremacy in our
organization and there's going to be a
whole
thing of it if they if they do it then
they're going to be actively infusing
their organizational culture with more
of this nonsense and it's eventually
going to lead to
the bottom line of having that bottom
line impact i don't know how this plays
out
until there's got to be one or two
ceos of major companies that stand up
and say we're not doing this this is our
business our business is not to fix
every problem with society our business
is to sell you socks
our businesses like the my pillow guy
probably our business is to sell you
pillows that's what we do and that's
what we're going to do
and colin i i it's very interesting all
the points you're making
but then sometimes i do read a study for
example it says that if you have a name
that is more african
or you know unless i say european you're
less likely to be
offered a job or an interview doesn't
that mean that therefore some of these
trainings are possibly beneficial
well i think and that's yeah that's a
that's a great question and you're
absolutely right there is research to
say that if you have a certain sounding
name you are less likely to be invited
in for an interview and you know this is
where
i we have to have a more nuanced
discussion about this is my
is my big issue with it because there
are very real problems
and very real conversations to have
about race in organizations and of
course in broader society and we can
have those conversations and
and think about ways to implement
trainings implement processes
implement procedures to counterbalance
some of these things and make sure
everyone in every organization has equal
access to
opportunity regardless of their race
their gender their
sexual orientation any of the things
those are real conversations to have
right now we cannot have those
conversations
because the only thing that people care
about is implementing
this anti-racist training so the nuance
is lost either you are doing it or you
are not if you are
doing it then you are good if you are
not doing it or
if you want to have a conversation about
different ways to approach these
problems
then you are bad
that's a very very important point to
make and it does
actually feel as if at the moment we are
arriving at the death of nuance and
everything is binary
and you're either red or blue all brexit
remain all the rest of it but
touching on politics we are entering a
very very interesting time in
in the political city in the political
um situation at the moment where we have
trump and he looks to be a little bit on
the downward slope
what what do you think about trump how
has he handled the situation and
can he get out of it i think trump can
absolutely get out of it i think trump
absolutely can win the election in
november i think he actually probably
will win
the election in november i mean listen
there hasn't even been a debate
between trump and biden yet and i think
that what we're seeing right now i don't
think that trump has handled the
situation
uh post george floyd's death perfectly i
think that there are a lot of things
that he could have done differently
i think that there was a lot that i
liked about how trump handled covet
there was some stuff that i didn't like
about how he
handled him he's like any other
president he is not perfect spoiler
alert trump is not
a perfect man nor is he a perfect
president
um but i do think he's going to come out
on top and the reason i think that
is because trump may not be perfect and
there may be plenty of problems that we
can have about him
but the democrats have gone off the
rails in the united states and if you
look at joe biden and i'm not i'm not a
clinical psychologist so i can say this
because i won't get in trouble like the
clinicians
joe biden has dementia joe biden in my
opinion has dementia it is absolutely
clear
and so we're basically deciding right
now between someone who is
a very deeply imperfect human being
and someone who doesn't know what state
he's in or what office he's running for
and so i mean i'm gonna take the
imperfect choice and i think that a lot
of americans will as well
i think it's interesting setting the
background to that colleen because i i
wanted to start the conversation about
your
your political journey you you've gone
from being a democrat
for 20 years to now supporting donald
trump but
actually it kind of started with
knitting is that right it did
it did it started with knitting so i am
an avid knitter
and so i you know when i say it starts
with knitting what people think of
are like knitting circles with old
ladies and tea
and you sit around and you know gossip
and all that stuff that's not actually
what it is for a lot of people today
knitting exists
primarily online like everything does
and so there are massive sites that
are deal primarily with knitting where
knitters interact and where i was mostly
interacting with people was on instagram
and you just see pictures of yarn and
projects and all this stuff and it's
supposed to be
fun and relaxing and not stressful at
all
until the social justice warriors took
over our
knitting community and started going
around
and harassing people with businesses um
the first woman they harassed it was
because she posted a blog post about
being very excited about going
on a trip to india and it wasn't it
wasn't okay that was not okay she had to
issue
a dramatic public apology outlining all
the reasons it was wrong for her to be
excited about going to india
the next person which included what
sorry like what
what's wrong with going to india but it
was wrong to be excited
because she was othering people and it
was like calling it it had something to
do with colonization and
it's still up on the internet today i
mean it's like a full blog post apology
outlining everything that she said was
wrong
um the next person they went after was a
woman who's a dyes hand
hand-dyed yarn her name's maria tuscan
and maria saw what was going on with the
initial bullying and
all she did was post a video saying i'm
not comfortable with this and i'm going
to leave instagram for a while and
for her troubles she was attacked and
mobbed by hundreds of people and had her
business destroyed and she's one of the
loveliest sweetest people you'll ever
meet in her life but apparently for them
she was just too white
to exist in the knitting community and
so they had to get rid of her but the
most distressing incident and the one
that actually got my attention
was a man actually a gay man in the
knitting community which men in the
knitting world are minorities
um he posted a poem about kindness and
just
asking people to be kind and empathetic
to each other and
he was mobbed so badly by thousands of
people
over the course of several days that he
eventually checked himself into the
hospital and was put on suicide watch
and so it really did i mean it's kind of
funny to think you know the knitting
community
but it really did have a very real
impact on very real lives and
at that point i started paying attention
i started going what is
this social justice stuff because i had
no i just really had no idea
and so once you wake up and you start
seeing it you kind of can't
unsee it and then as you all know you
start seeing it everywhere
but i'm just going to get my head around
this
so knitting right the knitting community
people sitting around with two needles
and a bowler and a ball of yarn
make him scarves and then we ended up by
talking about white supremacy and
colonization
oh i'll give you i'll give you another
one these are actually two two guys
in the uk actually they live in london
um they wrote a book called
knit and nibble which is all about
knitting and also baking desserts
and they went on some show that
apparently is about losing weight
hell in a healthy way to promote their
book as as people do when they write a
book
they want to promote it and these two
men were bullied and mobbed for
fat shaming and how dare you contribute
to this toxic
fat shaming industry when their whole
book was about desserts like this was
not a diet book
and so i mean there is no rhyme or
reason to why
they're making these attacks it's simply
that and i think we see this with
with the anti-racist training i think we
can look at any part of society that
social justice is impacted
it's not about white supremacy it's not
about equality it's not about
treating people well it's simply about
having something to be angry about and
if they don't have something to be angry
about because we've already talked about
creators and destroyers
destroyers need something to destroy
they will go and find something to be
angry about
and the people that we're doing this in
the knitting world and i do feel like
we're focusing on knitting quite a lot
but this is interesting because
and just for people who are watching
this maybe not be aware as you say what
happened
in your knitting community so to speak
happens everywhere
it's just one example of it so if we did
delve slightly deeper into that
were the people who who started bullying
the the people that you mentioned were
they kind of
existing members of the community or
were these people who came seemingly out
of nowhere
no they were existing members of the
community
but i mean and actually some of them um
there's actually a very big knitting
site ravelry that actually
ended up banning all support for donald
trump so you are not allowed to talk
about donald trump on the biggest
knitting site
on the internet so no i mean they were
definitely existing members of the
community but i'll tell you a funny
story about one of them
so the person that was leading the
charge against the
the man that eventually went into the
hospital in suicide watch
it was later discovered she actually
lives in the uk as well it was later
discovered
that she was running um a scam out of
her house
to sell handicapped children vacation
packages
and is currently in jail because of it
so i have to say there's a little bit of
vindication about
that just side note
they're always good people aren't they
really it's just terrific
moral human beings yeah but it just
feels so
surreal that even a subject as
uncontentious
as knitting who's now becoming you know
just riddled with violent anger it's
it's
it's utterly bizarre it's because it's
not about the knitting though
and this is what i think it's it's
really we need to hit this point home
um and your viewers know this it's not
about the knitting it's not about the
gaming
it's not about young adult fiction it's
not about it's not about
racism in the workplace it's not about
any of these things it's about having
something to be angry about
right so but i guess then the question
is and maybe i don't know if you feel
like you're the right person to answer
it but
why now colin why is it that now people
so many people all at once feel that
they've got to be angry about something
is it that
we've come we've done so well as a
civilization that there's nothing to be
angry about or is it
on the other hand rising inequality and
people genuinely have a reason to be
angry at something
like what is it about this moment that
that has erupted in this way
i think that's a really good question
and i don't know that i have a concrete
answer to it i have some theories about
it i think that
if i'm looking at the people that are
being really destructive
in this moment they're primarily younger
people right they're primarily people
under
you know 25 certainly under 30 for most
of them
and they never have their civil rights
movement i mean when i was younger i was
fighting
for for gay marriage to be legalized and
not i mean because i thought that was
something that was very important to me
that was part of the reason i became a
democrat is i wanted anyone to be able
to marry who they loved well
that was really one of the last big
battles of civil rights
in the united states i mean today if we
look at their marginalized groups i mean
we can talk about how you know trans
people struggle and i think there's
certainly conversations to be had there
but
can they do anything under the law that
i can do well yes
they can the the legal barriers to this
have been
have been torn down and so there has not
been
a civil rights battle for people to
struggle and i think when younger people
especially look back at the civil rights
era and the protests
i think there's something enticing about
that there's something enticing
about being part of the group that is
fighting for the moral
good of humanity but there's no battle
to fight so they had to create something
now i also don't think that social media
has helped matters any i think that
social media and the dopamine hits that
people get from those likes and having
those large followings and
they're always on their phones all the
time has only contributed to this
the other part of this though is that we
know that people who spend
a lot of time on social media or on
their phones they get clinically
depressed
they are much more likely to be
clinically depressed and so
where we're factoring in mental illness
into this affair and really
there's no people have not taught
them how to productively manage these
challenges how to productively cope
with these challenges what they are
doing is just feeding them more things
to be angry about so
i blame the education system number one
primarily that's the thing that i spend
the most time thinking about these days
is
how much our system of education at
least in the states and
i'm sure elsewhere as well um from
kindergarten all the way up through
higher education
how much our teachers have contributed
to this problem
because not only are they teaching a
very distorted version of history
but they're not teaching people how to
productively cope and how to actually
build things and become creators they're
only teaching them about
how to do negative things and don't you
think part of the problem as well carlin
is that
we've built you know twitter facebook
all the rest of it
and really we have tools that are so
powerful we don't even know the
long-term implications of being exposed
to these kind of things
and also let's be brutally honest it's
not in these companies best interests
to minimize your time on their platform
no no it's not in their best interest at
all and so they've got
all sorts i mean they they know exactly
what they need to do to keep you on that
platform to keep you doing post to keep
you to liking things
they they've got us all by by something
um i'll tell you that and and that's
well done for being inclusive there
colin very good
i don't want to make any assumptions
right um
no so i mean i this is this is a problem
and i don't know how we counteract this
um
because people are they're they're not
only addicted to social media but
also that anger that people are feeling
there is actually a physical addiction
to anger and to outrage that is just as
powerful as an addiction to cigarettes
or alcohol or sugar or any of these
things
and if we're constantly just feeding
people anger
we're not helping them to get over that
addiction
that's really interesting so people in a
sense just become addicted to that
to that emotion that emotion that that
they're feeling
and and do you think trump as a
president helps to kind of perpetuate
that anger when he puts out some from
some of his more there we say
inflammatory tweets i think trump takes
pride in in being inflammatory trump is
the ultimate troll for sure no i mean
trump is not helping this this is one of
my
biggest challenges with trump is that he
could
i i really think trump has had moments
in his presidency
where he could have worked to bring
people together and what does he do
he demonizes the other side just as much
as the other side has demonized him
there are no innocent people in this
scenario and
i think that um the challenge is that we
need to have people in leadership
positions
that are actually interested in solving
the problems not
interested in winning the fight being
interested in solving the problems
because
when you shift from winning the fight to
solving the problem
it's fundamentally different because
when you're trying to solve a problem
you have to come to the table and be
willing to compromise
be willing to debate different positions
be willing to
give up a little bit of your position to
give someone else a win so you could
bring them along you know what paul who
paul knew this as a politician
arnold schwarzenegger arnold
schwarzenegger of all people he
absolutely knew this arnold
schwarzenegger as a republican when he
was governor of california
he had democrats on his team he had a
whole little team of rivals going on
he also you know i i saw him speak at
south by southwest several years ago
and one of the things he talked about in
his talk i'll never forget it he was
talking about
how he brought all the stakeholders
around healthcare in california into the
same room
and to try to fix healthcare and he told
them going into it he said
none of you should expect to walk out of
here with a 10. the best you should
expect for is a seven because if you get
70 percent of what you want and you that
means you're giving other people a win
if you demand a hundred percent of what
you want that means that guys over there
is only going to get 30
of what he wants and he's not going to
go along with it and he's going to leave
entirely
we have forgotten that it's pretty good
to get 70 percent of what you want and
to give the other side a win
instead what everyone is doing is
digging their heels in until they can
get 100
of what they want and what that leads to
is everyone
getting nothing that's a really good
point that you make
and i guess the question is as we we
come to probably the last 10
minutes of the interview is how do we
start to set society back on the road to
the sensible
uh ideas that you make i mean for
example in the workplace how do we
how do we go back to or not maybe go
forward to
to to to that way of thinking i think
it's going to take people
in leadership positions that are going
to have to make
unpopular choices they're going to have
to say
no we're not doing this anti-racist
stuff because we are a pillow company
that is what we do we are going to do
the very best that we can to produce the
best pillows
that we possibly can and that does not
involve anti-racist training
and to have the courage to stand up and
do that and
you know i have a series of
conversations on my channel with dr
howard asher who's a psychotherapist out
in
los angeles and he says all the time he
says carlin people have to be willing
to be called a racist and to know that
is not the end
of the world and once people get over
that obstacle of being willing to be
called a racist then that frees them up
to make all sorts of decisions because
they are no longer at
the uh having fear of what the mob is
going to do to them
but isn't that a lot to ask from people
because
i've been i mean we both have been
called racist i've been called pro
fascists we have had
a deeply hurtful email written to me
from someone who i used to consider a
friend
explaining to me how i've now become a
mean and nasty person all the rest of it
all right it's not a therapy session
she's a psychologist he is therapy
but but my point is this isn't that a
lot to ask from people because these
words are
deeply hurtful well francis you're still
doing the
show yeah but i'm a narcissist i want
attention
well i mean then your desire to keep
doing the show has has become stronger
than your desire not to be called a
racist
yeah right i mean for business owners
this is this is going to be the decision
between do i want my company to be
successful and profitable
or do am i afraid of being called a
racist those that's the choice
and whichever one you want more is the
one that's going to win out
so suppose what you're really talking
about and it's a it's a running theme
through most of our recent interviews i
suppose is
you're talking about the need for people
to be courageous in the face of
bullying and in the face of uh peer
pressure
and pressure from above absolutely and i
think that this is actually it could
almost evolve into a solution for
society as well
but you have to know who you are
and if you know that you are a good
person and you do not
treat people differently based on the
color of their skin or who they love or
their gender or any of the other things
if you know that you are not a racist
then why would you listen to someone
else who tells you that you
are why are we giving other people
people who
are significantly more likely to have
mental health issues
why are we giving them that power over
us to tell us who we are
and what we believe but isn't there also
something to be said calling and that
we're all
let's be firm relatively privileged
positions you know that we have started
we've got our own platforms we've tried
to develop our own followings
a lot of people don't have those
advantages
well listen i didn't have any of what i
have now in terms of a platform went
before i wrote my trump rally article
and you know i'll admit it was very
scary for me to put it out there that i
went to a donald trump rally and it
turns out that they aren't racist in
nazis and kkk leaders and just normal
people
it is scary at first but it doesn't
require
you know eric weinstein tweeted um not
too long ago
that it requires fu money to stand up to
the mob
it does not require fu money it does not
require a platform
all it requires is a spine and we have
seen this
over and over and over again that people
who stand
up to the mob and do not bend the knee
the mob tends to leave them alone we saw
this in the knitting community
the knitting community is not unique in
that it was invaded by sjws
the knitting community is unique in that
it fought back
and is still fighting back hard against
the sjws and guess what happened
when a lot of us started fighting back
and speaking up
they stopped bothering us they came
after us a little while but then they
stopped bothering us and then once other
people saw
that they stopped bothering us they
started fighting back too
and all of a sudden you've got a lot of
people that have been given
that courage that they don't have giant
platforms they don't have fu money
but they're standing up and saying what
they believe and once you stand your
ground
the mob won't hurt you that's a really
interesting
point because i wrote an article
probably two or three weeks ago in the
spectator over here
about why i don't support the blm
organization and why neither should the
readers who are reading it
and i got almost no negative feedback on
it at all
it was quite extraordinary and i think
they've just kind of given up because
i'm i just clearly say to them i don't
care what you think and i'm going to
make fun of you
and i think if you do that and you just
stand up for what you believe
as you say i think over time they just
leave you alone because they're like oh
this person isn't actually vulnerable to
us
um do you think that's really what it's
about is
what they zone in and they hone in on
people who they sense are vulnerable and
who they sense are
susceptible to being bullied i think
that that's exactly what it is and i
actually wrote my doctoral dissertation
about workplace bullying in
organizations and
workplace bullying is a power game just
like what the sjws are doing it is a
power game
bullies hone in on the people who they
perceive
are not going to fight back because it
makes
them feel powerful and most bullies by
the way
are people who have been bullied at
other points in their lives or their
careers or whatever
and so that's how they learn how to
bully and when you're bullied
fundamentally that takes you out of
power
when they're bullying other people
that's the way that they're putting
themselves back in control
but if you stand in front of them and
make it very clear to them that you are
not going to allow this to happen to you
in and there are a bunch of different
ways to do that um
they will eventually back down because
you know what there is there's a
sea of people who are willing to allow
themselves to be bullied
they have got a lot of other options to
go to why why
spend energy on people who are simply
not going to take it and are going to
fight back and are going to
make your life more difficult when you
can just go right over to susie q who's
absolutely going to take it because
she hasn't learned this lesson yet and
if you were going to
put together just a little bit of a
guide or a certain point
for someone for someone who is going
through this type of online bullying
what advice would you give them the very
first thing i would say
is that you know get get off the
computer probably
like twitter is not real life social
media is not real life go
go out and be in the real world even in
the era of coronavirus you can still go
out and
be in the real world but i think the
most important thing is that
people need to start doing more inner
work
to build up their internal security
because if you have
internal security no one can knock you
off that rocker that's that's
that's in that's the nate to you no one
can take that away from you
the very best way to build up internal
security that i know of
is a regular daily practice of
meditation
people have got to start meditating and
i know that doesn't seem
like a direct route or even one that
makes sense but when you're when you're
meditating on a daily basis and there
are lots of ways to do this lots of free
programs people can use it's just a
matter of getting into the habit
you learn how to control your emotions
you learn how to put things in
perspective
you learn how to give yourself the love
and consideration
that you're looking for from other
people
and so it teaches you so many valuable
skills to be your own best friend to be
your own biggest supporter to be your
own biggest advocate
and that's what's going to develop that
internal security you try bullying
someone with internal security and you
watch what happens you're not going to
last very long
so people have got to do that for
themselves no one else can do it for you
that sounds like the tools of white
supremacy to me
well uh on that happy note i i was going
to say on that happy note but then
france is brought in white supremacy and
is a lot less happy all of a sudden
but on that note colin it's been
absolutely fantastic speaking with you i
think some of the insights you've given
us into
the workplace events that are ongoing
now and also
what you say about the importance of
building up your own
confidence and your courage uh are also
really really important in this
in this moment that we're in uh and with
that in mind the last question we always
ask
is what is the one thing that we're not
talking about
as a society that we really should be
talking about
i think that you know we've kind of
waffled around it a little bit in this
conversation but the thing that is
keeping me
up at night is how do we break this
addiction to anger and what i want
people to really understand is it is a
physical
addiction because what happens in your
mind makes its way into the body we see
this every time someone has a nightmare
um in terms of they wake up they're
sweating their their whole body's
clenched they feel like they just ran a
5k
even though they're laying in bed that's
our mind having a direct impact on the
body and
every time we're angry our brain sends
certain hormones into the body that
makes us physically feel that anger
how are we counterbalancing that that's
something i would like to hear a lot
more conversation about and how are we
counterbalancing it
not only for the adults that have this
addiction that are wreaking havoc on our
society but
how do we teach young children how to do
that so they don't grow up
and become an sjw that's the question
thank you very very much colin it's been
an absolutely superb interview
uh if people want to find you on social
media where would be the best place for
this
yeah one of the best places right now is
actually youtube i have my own channel
on here where i pontificate on the daily
i can also be found
on twitter at dr carlin b and on parlor
minds and gabs at carlin fantastic well
thank you very much for coming on the
show
and thank you everybody for watching
listening we will see you very soon with
a live stream
or another brilliant episode absolutely
all our episodes and all our live
streams go out at 7pm
uk time that's 7pm uk time see you soon
guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word